there's been controversy at the oscar
ceremony in hollywood will smith has
apparently hit comedian chris rock the
comedian had made a joke about smith's
wife jada pinkett smith a few minutes
later smith won best actor for his
performance in king richard a film about
the father of venus and cyrilla williams
smith won't be charged over the incident
as rock has declined to file a police
report stephen gaidos is executive
editor of variety magazine he joins us
now live from los angeles
stephen i suppose we've got to start
with that incident which overshadowed
was which was i mean let's face it a
pretty lackluster show
what did you make of it
uh well i agree completely it was a very
lackluster show i i would say a terrible
show
and it was made lively by something very
strange unfortunate and violent it was
an act of violence he uh strode on the
stage unexpected
slapped or punched chris rock in the
face for what he said and screamed uh
curses at him and swore at him and went
back to his seat and the show continued
the show must go on they say in
hollywood
um he then went on to win best actor
what did you make of his acceptance
speech
well um i think it was fairly unhinged
but given the circumstances of having
assaulted another human being on
stage at the oscars only minutes earlier
i
i'm sympathetic to the feeling of being
a bit unhinged he tried to apologize not
to chris rock but to the academy and the
people he made the film with it was uh
tearful it was emotional i think it was
heartfelt but it was heartfelt as if you
were watching a person in the midst of a
nervous breakdown all right and as far
as the the academy awards themselves a
concerned coder won best picture uh
jessica chastain uh for best actress for
the eyes of tammy faye as we said uh
will smith won best actor did the awards
go to the right people
well that usually is not the case but
when you work at variety as long as i
have and love movies as long as i've
loved movies
that goes with the territory
i think power of the dog is a movie for
the ages i think it stands
will stand the test of time and stands
alongside the great westerns ever made
in hollywood but that's one uh person's
opinion the academy did not agree
despite sean penn saying that he would
smelt his uh his trophies if uh
president zelinski of ukraine didn't
appear he didn't in fact there was there
was hardly any mention really of ukraine
very very minimal and uh we did not get
zielinski but we got liza minelli
okay and there were lots of um there was
lots of criticism about last year's
ceremony perhaps in terms of diversity
being the worst ever was this
ceremony diverse enough do you think
well i think it was admirable in the
sense that uh
there was a lot of diversity in the uh
honorees and the nominees
as well as the winners
a person of color one best actor a
openly gay uh woman of color one
supporting actress a black filmmaker won
best documentary film uh there and and
coda won all three of the awards it was
nominated for and it is a film 100
about the disabled community and
celebrating actors in that disabled
community and their ability to make a
powerful emotional uh terrific movie
stephen really good to talk to you many
thanks indeed for being with us stephen
gaidos the executive editor of variety
magazine in los angeles